[Music]
so many people have a preconceived
notion of what I am capable of just at
first sight when I do my thing and they
see it and they're like woah I love
giving that shock and awe feeling it's
just like so you think I can only do
this but I'm going to show you I can do
so much more my name is Dexter Mayfield
and I am a plus-sized male model and
professional dancer for about eight
years now oh my goodness the journey has
been long it has been hard being a
bigger person there's not as many
opportunities but at the same time
there's so many opportunities that you
would never expect I'm so happy so I've
been able to dance for Jennifer Lopez
for her poppy music video Sara Bareilles
for her brave music video I was actually
able to walk the runway as a plus-size
model for Marco Marco at LA Fashion Week
and that has been an eye-opening
experience for me I was never actually
trained professionally as a dancer I
never expected to be a professional
dancer given my body type being a gay
black man in America is not easy
especially being a big gay black man in
America and it took me a while to really
find that love for myself my true self
whenever we think of bigger men we view
them as something to laugh at and we're
not that we love our bodies as well and
we are sexy too like I can't say that
enough like we are sexy too
at the end of the day I just want to be
seen as someone who deserves this is
someone who is capable not seen as just
an overweight person not just seen as a
black actor or dancer and not seen as
whatever that first impression is I just
want to be seen as someone who is
talented enough for this job
[Music]
please put your hands together for
Danielle Perez yes keep it going for
those strong gentlemen keep it going for
them lifted me onstage I'm gonna hit
them up for a foot massage later when
I'm on stage and I'm performing
I feel really powerful what I'm saying
is being like telegraphed to all these
people that are there to hear my story
and be exposed to you know a Latina
who's disabled and in a wheelchair it's
just a really important thing to be
onstage representing that my name is
Nell Perez and I'm a stand-up comedian
performing stand-up comedy while using a
wheelchair is a bit of a challenge first
of all people are always a little
they're just thrown off they don't
really get what's going on I'm really
excited to be here tonight just debuting
my new look which is aggressively fat
yet still very judgy
I started comedy three years ago I
realized I love doing comedy after my
first open mic people laughed at me and
that felt so good like I wanted to hold
on to that feeling forever I was like I
need to do more of this I'm a big girl
but I can tell that I've gained a little
bit of weight because people keep asking
me if I have diabetes which is really
rude because I was hit by a train I've
gone through a lot of dark things eating
disorders depression
I lost my feet when I was 20 I
definitely use comedy to speak about
those things but also to entertain and
through that find healing and myself
I think that comedy is really helpful
tool in healing and bringing people
together when you see someone on stage
that is sharing a story or telling a
joke and you're like oh I got that I do
that too it unifies and brings people
together and it's a form of catharsis I
go sit on my therapist about two years
ago but realized I should get back into
it when I started daydreaming about
walking into traffic and I don't have
feet I think the message that I want to
put out in the world is that it's okay
to be yourself it's okay to be weird and
different you're only given one
opportunity in this world so make it the
best you can
[Music]
I was told give up and I have to live
with my red discoloration on half of my
face for the rest of my life and I felt
like I don't want to give up on myself
I'm gonna go out there and find a
solution
my name is Baz Muhammad and I help
people heal from the inside out I am a
micropigmentation specialist I
camouflage all types of scars birthmarks
and burns I implant pigment in scar
tissue to eliminate any discoloration in
the skin when I was 2 years old I was
playing in the kitchen with my brother
and fire started a hot oil ended up
spilling on 50% of my face I ended up
with third-degree burns and I've had
almost a hundred different types of
surgeries and laser treatments and none
of them were successful I would just
talk to my plastic surgeon I asked him
what can I do and he said just take your
money go on a vacation this is the end
for you we can't improve it I said what
about permanent cosmetics can I get my
eyebrow tattooed and he said it's the
worst thing you can do for yourself scar
tissue will never pick up pigment so
that day I decided I'm gonna go and have
my eyebrows tattooed my scar tissue
picked up the pigment
from that moment I thought why not make
skintone pigments and implant that
pigment in the scar tissue to eliminate
the discoloration I started apprenticing
with a permanent makeup artist I learned
everything that I needed to know about
skin I decided to be my first client and
work on my own face I was able to
camouflage all the red discoloration and
I had something that actually worked
originally when I started it I wanted a
solution for myself but from there it
had like a much bigger purpose we have
the clinic in Toronto Canada and we have
the clinic now in Beverly Hills and we
performed this procedure every single
day now we reached a point where Plastic
Surgeons reach out to us they want to
learn more about the procedure we've
performed thousands of procedures in the
last 15 years and it's clients that find
from all over the world every year we
take on few big cases and we donate
those treatments Adela has a point stain
on her face and she's had so many
different types of treatments and
nothing really has worked for her
very thankful for her too because she's
making my dream come true you know I
used to use the heavy makeup to cover it
now
layer a layer it's a big difference it
used to be four times more trade the
best part about this it's seeing people
transform and that's why I'm so grateful
that I never gave up on my journey I was
able to help thousands of people it's
amazing what you can do when you're just
authentic it's amazing what you can do
when you just true to yourself I am a
woman with a beard
when a beard is supposed to be a manly
thing my name's Hannah Nam Kham 26 years
old I work as an anti-bullying activist
and I model to polycystic ovary syndrome
is as simple as saying that I have more
testosterone in my body than the female
sex hormone and the side effect of the
condition is weight gain or weight loss
diabetes alopecia obviously facial hair
in school I was bullied horrendously
because of the way that my body was I
thought that the building would stop if
I removed my facial hair so I started
tweezing bleaching waxing shaving using
hair removal creams but the hair growth
just came back even longer darker
thicker I was at the age of 16 and I hit
my lowest I was very suicidal and I was
just sick and tired of all the body
shaming and bullying and people not
letting me live my life say what I want
- I thought right you're gonna grow your
beard out and see how you like her and
see how she forms in your face
[Music]
I obviously look after my bed I've given
her name as old sunder Lee I think a lot
of men just look at me because my beard
says sometimes a lot better than theirs
sorry all the negativities I went
through I turned into something positive
and I made a career out of it you know
I'm in the media actually everywhere
very fortunate to you know to be able to
reach such vast amount of people because
there are so many women out there even
men that suffer from body shaming but
don't speak about it one woman said I'm
not suicidal because of you so that to
me just really ensured to me that yeah
you know what you're doing is positive
in having a positive effect on people if
there was a pill that could reverse all
this no would never take it I can't say
I love this but I don't love that no
100% love myself
you
you